when I taped uh the voice over for Your
Love Letter you have since um uh been
nominated um for a Golden Globe and a
sag award for niad so that
happens I have to tell you the movie
that has affected me most in my life um
that I've seen in this past year without
question is niad oh thank you it is they
must
see there's
there are so many important Universal
compelling life themes in the movie um
and the fact that you refused to have a
body double to help aid in the physical
demands I mean this is niad this is the
woman who swims who broke every record
who defied all possible logic of what
could or couldn't be done by a human
being well I you know when I started
that when I when I read it I loved it I
knew I wanted to do it and I didn't
really think it through I didn't really
think through the swimming the physical
part of it I'm in a bathing suit I'm 62
starting when I when I started the movie
never looked hotter by the way you have
like the most beautiful body well thank
you I was swimming a lot uh and I had a
great I had an Olympic swimmer Raa Owen
who was my swim coach and she really
instilled in me this belief that I could
do it I I'd been in the water a lot I
was a diver scuba diver as a kid which
we're going to get into later because
you were on a boat and we have a cooking
segment and that Benning is going to do
her first cooking segment on television
so I'm looking so forward to that first
time for everything I know if we get to
do it here I'm so excited so you do all
of this physical work yes well for Diana
niad who I got to play when she turned
60 she decided to to do the marathon
swim that she had failed to do in her
20s yes but she had been a hardcore
athlete all of her early years and this
is Cuba to Key West never been done by a
human ever so at 60 she decides to do it
and she goes to to her best friend and
she says okay Bonnie I want to do the
swim and you have to be my partner and
be my trainer and Bonnie says the
logical thing Diana you couldn't do it
when you were in your late 20s what
makes you think you can do it now and
she says I didn't have this I didn't
have the brain that I have now and she
says yeah but you don't have the body
you you know you're 60 how can this be
how can you even think that this is
possible and and she just put her mind
to it you know when she finally did
achieve it and it took her many many
attempts and she started when she was 60
and she finally did it when she was
64 she lands on the beach and she says
one never ever give up two you're never
too old to chase your dreams and three
it looks like a solitary sport but it
takes a team and uh so Diana for me
that's why I loved it I was just
inspired by it personally when I read it
I was moved and it's not so it's not so
much about the swim it's really more
about her journey as a human being and
her friendship with this woman you know
my friendships now they've always been
so important to me and I've got buddies
i' I've literally got a friend from when
I was 10 years old yeah but my female
friendships are so vital right to my
emotional well-being that's why the
story that's why I love the story
because it's around the swim that the
that it activates the and you really see
the Dynamics between these to women who
are so deeply connected but yet have you
know they have to go through a lot
because of Diana's obsession with the
swim